well today Carson City is a whole lot
busier a new legislative session started
with a very busy agenda and divided
branches of government today mostly Pomp
and Circumstance both parties did Lay
the foundation for what's to come John
langler is live now in Carson City
joining us live with more John
Brian good evening to you here at the
legislative building it is controlled by
democrats just down the street of the
capitol of course new Republican
Governor Joe Lombardo is settling into
his second month in office but now the
stage is set for making things happen
here in Carson City that affects all of
Nevada
[Music]
this is all new to assemblyman yui
Nguyen it's his first time in Carson
City as a state lawmaker exciting and
nervous at the same time the Democrat
represents Spring Valley the first Asian
American Pacific Islander to represent a
neighborhood where it's the majority uh
wait for me to make sure that all voices
are at the table and and making sure
that you know we open doors for more
the tables are full now lawmakers from
across Nevada are settling in for 120
days of making laws I'm looking forward
to the session and making good policy
for the state of Nevada policy everyone
seems interested in revolves around
education both sides want to increase
investment and improve performance
really trying to make a difference for
nevadans and education and Health Care
making sure that we strengthen our
economy so that we can continue with
this robust budget Republican Governor
Joe Lombardo's 11 billion dollar budget
includes more per pupil funding but is
it enough to satisfy Democrats one of
the key goals that we have within the
funding formula is making sure that the
funding formula gets funded so that is
something that we believe needs uh in
some sort of investment this upcoming
session everyone here has their own
agenda it's the nature of politics now
the agenda and campaign promises meet up
with the reality of government
119 days to go a lot to do in 120 days
[Applause]
and and on that note dozens of bills
were introduced in the legislative
session after the announcements were
made of the introductions they're going
to be assigned to committees and then
the real work gets underway one of the
first topics though that is expected to
be dealt with increased pay for state
workers live in Carson City John langler
8 News Now